All right, welcome to another Zoom call.
A number of questions, so let's jump into them, a couple of reminders.
All of our patients are now eligible to log into the courses for free.
They're still added cost to those.
Use your say user name.
Use your same user name we've asked you to do for the members site.
Also, since our last Zoom call member, we're talking about doing nebulized hydro peroxide using Dr. McCollus formula.
Somebody was so gracious to share that document that is on the home page.
You can click and download that formula for nebulized hydro peroxide that that that would be for.
If you're having any fungal or any issues with your lungs, actually, if you feel like your lungs are congested.
You just got a bad cold to worst knowing you have, you know, a fungal infection or pneumonia.
That's a great protocol to use to help with your lungs.
Okay, also the courses being free to school to our website.
Look at the top of the page, you'll see courses, click on that button and you'll come to this page.
I just got a screenshot of this page.
And those are the courses that are available for your leisure.
Again, use your same user name to pass word that you do for the membership site.
All right, let's jump into the questions.
Also from the blog that you recommend a reverse osmosis system for filtering drinking water.
But until we invest in that, we have a burky filter for drinking cooking and animals. Is that okay for them?
So I recommend a reverse osmosis system if you don't have a system.
So if you have a burky, just use the burky.
There's no reason for you to get a different filter.
A burky is a great filter. You don't need to invest in a reverse osmosis.
Just if you already have the burky, use the burky.
What are your thoughts on distilled water distilled water is fine too.
The whole idea is you want to stop consuming water with chlorine and fluoride in the worst things for you.
Especially the fluoride is just so destructive on your body, so destructive on your neural tissue.
So personally, we have well water.
We've had it tested. It's really good well water.
We don't use a filter at all.
So we're not getting chlorine. We're not getting fluoride.
So we don't use a filter at all. When we lived in the small city that we're next to.
Of course, we had city water. We used a reverse osmosis system by children that are not in their permanent home right now have two younger daughters who are married in their 20s.
They are not in a permanent home right now. They use a burky filter.
So they're not getting a reverse osmosis system.
Because that's installed and they have to uninstall it and take it with them if they will.
So burky is a great unit, so just to use that reverse osmosis is just more convenient in a permanent situation.
So with ER positive breast cancer and hormones listed as a cause of my cancer after cheek swab testing plus on a low history diet, how much emphasis, if any, should I put on limiting estrogetic foods, the list is long.
But coffee is one of those things on the list.
Is a cup of coffee okay. How is it that coffee animals are so good for us if coffee is estrogetic.
Is there a need to balance progesterone when you have your positive cancer, or does it have to wait for genetic testing results to come back to see if there's a metabolic problem.
So coffee can be estrogetic, but it's mild on the low side of that list. The biggest things that you want to look at are plastics, things that are going to be estrogen disruptors in your body.
It's certainly taking any bioidentical hormone replacement you have to be careful with, even with progesterone, because progesterone excess progesterone will store your fat cells and then will aromatize through aromatase and the enzyme that breaks that down into other hormones and it could aromatase into the four hydroxy esterone, which is the bad estrogen.
So if you want to be on progesterone, typically, if we're on, if we have an ER or PR or for two positive cancer, any one of those three positive, we would stay up a progesterone.
Coffee is not, yes, too much coffee is an issue.
And we'll look at your genetics when we get those back to.
We have a couple coffee, coffee, animals are good for you because they stimulate your parasympathetics, you're not absorbing a lot of the caffeine that's in that.
So your worst estrogen issues, estrogen causing issues would be GMO foods, plastics, especially plastics that have been heated.
So a hot water bottle in your car that's heated up by the sun, you're getting a release of a lot of zero estrogens in there.
So you have to be careful of those things, those are things that a person should be careful of, even if you're a male with no cancer.
So certainly, even if you don't have cancer, you should still be cognizant of staying away from zero estrogens.
But coffee, a cup of coffee a day is just fine, I don't see any harm in that.
Is there any benefit to holding the right bomb over the side of the tumor for a time?
Yes, so I think there's huge benefit to having the right is close to your body as possible and as close to the tumor site as possible.
The only caveat to that is if you have brain cancer and you're putting it right over your head in it all night long and it's keeping you awake.
You don't want the bulb to keep you awake, but I've had patients with neck cancer, they put them all right up there and it's glaring them all night long and they say, well, doesn't bother me.
I sleep just fine.
If you're sleepy, just find ham and it's close to the cancer as possible.
You need those frequencies will go through you and will dissipate through your body, but just use, you know, some common sense, get it as close to the cancer site as possible.
You're going to have been the best results.
I just got a mini size infrared heating pan from Therassage and I've used it overnight a few times.
It has a velcro strap so I can snug it over my breast tumor under our next to the suspicious lymph node, but doing this blocks the rife.
That's OK, the rife will go through that just fine.
The heating pad also has jade stones in it. I could use velcro.
I could velcro the pad around me. The only thing you have to be careful with the heaty pad we love that Therassage heating pad.
And I know the owner of the company we sell that heaty pad in our store as well.
They're just a great company to deal with.
A great product. Only they get to be careful about it is make sure you don't burn yourself. So that has been an issue with people in the past, especially if you put it over an area that you don't have a lot of great sensation.
So just be careful of that. That's my only caveat to any heating pad at all.
That this one you can turn it up high. So make sure you turn the temperature down so you're not going to burn yourself, especially if you fall asleep at night.
If so, what's the best one? Just the way you're doing it combined that I think that's a great thing to do.
My college is ran a bone scan, which came back good. Now he wants a dexter scan.
Will this tell anything different? So what he's looking for with a dexter scan is osteoporosis or any bone loss.
Is there anything wrong with doing that? No, except that I'm not in favor of what he would recommend if there is any bone loss, which is a drug, which is a horrible drug.
To help prevent any bone fractures, there is a good to prevent osteoporosis. So the osteoporosis medication that's out there comes in various forms and it has various labels now.
But all it does is make hard brittle bones. All it does is increase the density of the periosteum, which is the outer part of the bone and doesn't allow that effect.
It prevents calcium in minerals, the mineralization of the endosteum, which is the inner part of the bone that actually gives you strength.
So why do they still use it? Actually, there's studies that prove what I just said is true. They still use it because it is a extremely profitable drug.
And it's the only thing they have for bone density. So I wouldn't, you can certainly do a dexter scan. There's nothing wrong with that.
I just would do some research on the drug that they would recommend if there's any issues.
A YouTube video popped up this morning about the imaging test. Do you know when that will become available in the story again?
Probably never in that form. The imaging test company went under during 2020, during COVID issues.
They just weren't, they were a great test that was pushed to
to alternatively minded practitioners testing for cancer, measuring.
And the score for cancer, it was a great test we used it a lot.
But when COVID hit and people weren't going into their functional doctors anymore, they just, just their company just ended up folding, they just weren't getting it up orders.
But these equipment costs are just so astronomical. And it's, so it's a very expensive to run those labs, especially be a clear approved lab, which they were, you have to follow all these guidelines and all these approvals.
And you really, if you're going to have a lab, you have to have a clear approved lab these days, I wouldn't use a lab that's not, unless I do more about it.
But they just could not, they just could not stay in business and they hold it. So I don't see that lab coming back.
When I started using the right a few weeks ago, I experienced significant pain in the area where I had mastectomy done that paid us pretty much subsided. Now the pain is on the other side, but not as severe.
I feel it mostly in my chest neckline and shoulder primarily with movement, any thoughts or recommendations. Yes, I have a blog post on good pain, bad pain, I would consider this to fall into the good pain category. So whatever you are running the right, especially when you're doing it, running the right for your cancer, it's not uncommon.
No, it certainly doesn't happen all the time. It's not uncommon in a person experiences pain.
At the site of the cancer, that's not a bad thing. That's actually a good thing. You're getting a reaction and a muted reaction to the area.
So I think that's a good thing. I would keep doing exactly what you're, what you're doing as far as your protocols. That's a good thing.
I received my bio results. However, I didn't locate my variant results. I think this person is talking about their genetic results, because I just sent those out to this person last week.
And yes, I do apologize. I will reset the file, the genetic, the full genetic report to everybody I attached it to other email and didn't go through because it's such a big file. So I have to send that separately.
It's like a 250 page document. So I'll send that out to you separately. I'll get that out.
Okay, that's all the questions that we had anything else from our listeners today.
I'm going to ask that all of you pray for Anne in her family. I am doing Anne's Monday.
Zoom call. Obviously, like, where's Anne? I like her better. She's nicer.
So I'm doing Anne's Zoom call because two weeks ago her son was diagnosed her 19 year old son that she asked me to have to tell you all this so that you would be praying for him.
He was diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia.
He was so sick. He couldn't get out of bed. She will fill you in on more details when she gets back, but he was just near death at home. There's nothing that he was, he was just so, so ill had to go to the emergency room several times for those who understand what leukemia is acute myeloid leukemia in a young person.
It tends to be pretty severe and I can be extremely life threatening.
As we get older, acute myeloid is just as severe, but more tolerated.
He was perfectly healthy had no issues and was hit with this started having literally was she just started having symptoms in about 10 days, and he just crashed so severely.
We do, there was something going on, we got a blood test and his blood was way off, his white blood cell count was low, his platelets were down to next to nothing.
It was quite serious. So just be praying for her and him, his name is AJ.
And he was a very healthy 19 year old, very physically fit muscular kid, very athletic.
So this just came out of the blue for him. And it's just another sad testimony to, I think, especially with the leukemias and blood cancers are almost always related to pesticides and herbicides and our environment to chemicals and our environment is just a sad testimony to how
history companies are just destroyed our population. And so just be keeping them in the, in your prayers, he is actually doing really well with the chemo.
He has to be in the hospital for 21 days doing chemo, they weren't even going to let him out, it was just so serious.
He really well, he's responded really well, he's got the right in the hospital running it 24, 7, and interesting, the oncologist and told me yesterday that the oncologist was really open minded.
She was running the right one him, no matter what, but the one of the oncologists came in and asked what it was.
And he's like, huh, he looked it up. And he goes, that's really interesting. I'm really excited about that. That's really interesting.
So, that very often that you get that. So,
know that we're praying for you guys, nobody's cancer is anymore or less important than anybody else's, but she just wanted to.
She asked me to tell everybody so that that she said, I want everybody to know that we're all in this together and the more prayers, the better.
Can we send cards of encouragement or maybe just emails you can certainly email and email.
She's not looking at that right now, but I will, I will copy and text it to her because I told her not to look at her email.
So, if you have been emailing and Q questions and things, continue to do that because I'm responding to you. Sometimes I put Dr. C on the response.
If you did see my response, sometimes I don't, so just know that that's me responding on hands email right now. But I will text it to her if you send it to me via hands email. So thank you for that.
Alright, any other questions.
Alright, thank you for using the membership site. Make sure you keep looking back at it.
But if you get if you do want to learn out, you can jump on any of these courses as well, you want to learn more about your genetics.
And the read your genes course is great. You have any questions about your right, the frequency healing course is good.
Most of the videos in the frequency healing courses are on your member site on the right page, but hey, you might might be something in there that I put in there that I don't have on the other things.
Alright, let's say to everybody know that I prayed for you, prayed for all of you guys and just keep up the good work, stay hopeful and praise worthy in all things.
I know that God's got his hand on you and there's no surprises in his book whatsoever. So he knows what you're going through. He just wants you to climb up on his lap and he wants to cuddle you and hug you and kiss you and tell you everything's going to be okay.
So if you do get fearful, use fear to drive yourself to him, use that anxiety to to drive yourself to him in his arms.
Alright, I love you all. I'll see you on Wednesday. Bye-bye.